john langler right now president joe
biden is giving a speech
talking about fighting the coronavirus
across state lines here he is giving the
speech right now one of his new mandates
in the white house
people have to wear masks for interstate
travel on public transportation
now we're going to have a recap of his
executive orders and some of the actions
he's taken already today
a little bit later on eight news now but
with more on the president's first full
day in the oval office here's skyler
henry from capitol hill
president joe biden began his first full
day in office with a virtual prayer
service
the new president is focusing on the
nation's covet 19 response
this afternoon signing 10 executive
orders which will among
other things provide guidance to safely
reopen schools
provide up to 100 million vaccine doses
by the end of april
and invoke the defense production act to
enable that goal the big
issue here which may seem obvious to
many is supply we need more supply of
not just the vaccines
but the materials to get them in the
arms of americans to effectively get
this done
president biden will also be meeting
with dr anthony fauci and his
coronavirus team
president biden says today's executive
actions will help but acknowledges he
will need congress's help to achieve
these goals
long way to go these are just executive
actions
they are important but we're going to
need legislation for
a lot of things we're going to do
already there is pushback from senator
mitt romney
and other gop senators to the
president's proposed 1.9 trillion
coronavirus relief package we just
passed a a
a program with over 900 billion dollars
in it
i'm not looking for a new program in the
immediate future the white house says
president biden plans to meet with
congressional leaders soon
to discuss how to move the package
forward skylar henry cbs news
capitol hill